Listen closely. It’s very important that you
pay attention to the visuals you’re seeing,
and the words you’re hearing. You may think
you’ve heard this story before. You get that
funny feeling. Deja Vu. But trust me, this is
all very much new to you. This is the story
of a dangerous species of anomalous creatures
dubbed SCP-939, also known as “With Many Voices.”
October 28th, 1981. It all started with an SCP
Foundation Field Agent going missing while on
duty. The whole case had smelled like death from
the beginning. On the edge of an undisclosed city
in an undisclosed American state, civilians
had been going missing in unusually high
numbers. This would be a concerning state of
affairs in and of itself, but things went up
a notch when the law enforcement operatives
sent to investigate them disappeared too.
Disappearances are hard enough to cover up;
law enforcement disappearances are a nightmare.
If only it’d stopped there. When
the Foundation agent went missing,
alarm bells were ringing across the entire
district. What the hell kind of threat could
take out civilians, trained law enforcement
officers, and even Foundation operatives?
Naturally, the next step in this escalation
of force was to dispatch a heavily-armed and
well-prepared Tactical Security Force
- known as Trapper - from the nearest
Foundation containment site. These were six of
the best tactical operators from the sector.
Whatever it was that killed or took the
others, it wouldn’t do the same to them.
Or at least...Not all of them.
The team breached an abandoned multi-level
warehouse on the edge of town. Based on the
estimated points of disappearance for the various
victims, it was the most feasible location
of an anomalous threat. They used explosive
charges to enter the building, and stormed in,
assault rifles and submachine guns blazing.
The team split up to search different parts
of the complex - In a move that even the Mystery
Gang could tell you doesn’t often work out well.
Though many Scooby Doo episodes
might’ve played out differently
if Shaggy was wielding a Heckler & Koch HK416.
It didn’t take long for the overpowering stenches
of death and decay to assail the team’s nostrils.
They’d worked for the SCP Foundation
for long enough to know the distinctive
sickly-sweet aroma of rotting human flesh
from memory. With heightened awareness,
they continued through the building,
searching for the source of that awful smell.
A member of the team radioed in when
they made the first grisly discovery:
The corpse of the missing Foundation field
agent, killed by what seemed to be one
huge bite, taking a fatal chunk from his neck.
Some kind of animalistic beast had taken his
life in a single decisive strike. Once again, the
danger level had elevated for the Trapper Team,
but it was about to get a whole
lot worse for all of them.
Some of the team that had split to check the
upper floors of the warehouse suddenly heard the
most terrible shrieking from the lower levels.
They heard their teammates calling for help,
clearly distressed. They weren’t even using their
radios. They just kept screaming and yelling,
begging the others to come
down there and help them.
But as the rest of the team
descended into the lower levels,
they soon realized that they’d been lured
into a trap by beasts far more intelligent
and diabolical than they’d ever imagined. This
was the story of the first time SCP Foundation
operatives ran into specimens of SCP-939
and lived to tell the tale. In the darkness
below that abandoned warehouse building,
they discovered a teeming den of monsters.
Large, quadrupedal beasts with translucent
red skin and long, vicious spines streaking
their back. Trails of human flesh dangled
from their long fangs. The monsters were
standing atop the corpses of the team members
who’d been calling for help moments before.
Or rather, seemed like they were calling for
help moments before. The SCP-939 instances
had borrowed the voices of their prey to order
a slightly more substantial dinner from above.
One of the two most potent abilities of SCP-939
is their power to mimic voices and do so with
genuinely terrifying accuracy. It is currently
unknown to the Foundation how exactly they do this
because 939 specimens don’t actually need
to hear a voice before they can imitate it.
And the complex structure of their imitations
and speech patterns suggests a far greater
level of intelligence than their more
superficially bestial nature implies.
Theoretically, you could hold an entire
conversation with a 939 behind a screen door
and have no idea that your conversation
partner was a creature that would be
just as happy to chew the head off your
neck as they would be to talk to you.
Speaking of which, back to the Trapper Team. The
survivors were cornered by a gaggle of monsters
using the voices of their dead teammates.
The creatures advanced with dripping fangs,
preparing to lunge and add another few bodies to
the count. Thankfully, the survivors thought fast,
opening fire and escaping out into
the hall as the creatures pursued.
After a tense firefight, and calling in a hefty
contingent of reinforcements from the nearby
containment site, the Trapper Team just barely
got the situation under control, narrowly avoiding
becoming just another voice in the repertoire
of this particular 939 nest. The Foundation
were able to capture several viable specimens
and bring them in for containment and study.
While some lives were lost,
the monsters were caught. But
939 stands apart from the rest of the
anomalous crowd in a number of ways,
including the fact that it's true horrors
were only unleashed after containment.
The Trapper Team that’d fought
tooth and nail to apprehend the
creatures in the first place began to
behave strangely during debriefing.
Despite their communication devices recording a
relatively clear audio account of the incident,
the survivors experienced odd lapses in memory.
Details that likely would have been burned into
the mind of anyone else experiencing these events
were completely absent from the recollections
of the team members. It was a phenomenon
the Foundation had only seen once before:
It was the exact kind of behavior exhibited
by people who’ve undergone amnestic treatment.
It was this comparison that led them
to discovering SCP-939’s second potent
anomalous effect: They quite literally
breathe a form of aerosolized amnestic,
dubbed AMN-C227. It inhibits the part of the
brain that allows people to form memories for the
duration of their exposure to the gas, creating a
kind of memory camouflage that 939 specimens are
able to hide in. The gas is odorless, colorless,
and tasteless. You could be standing in a room
full of it and never even know. The only tell
that you’d even had memories erased by AMN-C227
is a strange sense of deja vu you’ll experience
if you return to the point of exposure.
It was an amnestic compound so effective,
the Foundation floated the idea of using it
for their own purposes, seeing as it’s
a lot easier to get AMN-C227 from 939
than the usual method of
sacrifices to Anantashesha.
From perfect voice mimicry to impeccable
memory erasing, with the added bonus of
intelligent pack hunting and an exceedingly
powerful bite strength, 939 appeared to be a
species of perfect predators for luring in and
killing humans. Naturally, the Foundation had
questions. Chief among them being: What the
hell are these things, and how do they work?
The more the Foundation experimented on SCP-939,
the more they became keenly aware of the fact that
these things don’t operate like any other living
being. Almost all of their internal systems - from
veins to their digestive system - are entirely
vestigial. Beneath their translucent skin, these
monsters are effectively dead. Nothing works,
and somehow, nothing needs to work. They consume
human flesh, but the flesh simply rots in their
stomach until they later vomit it out. Nothing
about their biology explains how they produce
amnestics, or how they even technically survive.
One sample was fully dissected, its different
vital systems placed into various tubes.
And the monster still tries to talk to
Foundation personnel as they walk past its
containment location. Some of the creature’s
childish ranting was recorded for posterity,
and the recordings are nothing
short of truly chilling.
“Have you seen our pictures? We like drawing.
Daddy hung them on the wall except for sometimes
when the others in white coats took them away.
Daddy told us not to draw pictures
like those. They made him sad,
so we did our best to draw other things, but
sometimes we forgot. Sometimes daddy hid the
pictures or ripped them up. He told us it wasn't
that he didn't like them. He said it was to keep
us safe from the mean doctors in the white
coats, but then the doctors took daddy away.”
And some of the things said by this dissected
creature have been even more disturbing:
“We got so hungry. It was bad, but we ate our
old skin and our old head. It tasted good,
but it was still bad. We were still
hungry after that and asked for food.
They gave us food, even our favorites,
but none of it tasted right to us.
All that tasted good was one piece
of meat. We asked for more of that.”
In hopes of understanding their biology
better, the Foundation also decided to run
some samples through SCP-914, The Clockworks.
As expected, the Coarse and Rough settings
destroyed and deconstructed the creature.
The data on the 1:1 setting was redacted,
but most frightening of all was the results
of the Fine and Very Fine Experiments.
For the Fine setting, the creature simply
came back dead. For the Very Fine setting,
the creature had been reduced to a smoldering
pile of white ash. The only conclusion we
can take from this is that, on a truly
cosmic level, 939 is meant to be dead.
And just when you think that SCP-939
has hit the ceiling on true horror,
the monsters continue to impress
by raising that nightmarish bar.
After eleven years in containment, one of
the 939 specimens gave birth to a litter of
infants. This doesn’t seem all that horrifying,
seeing as being able to reproduce would at least
give 939 something in common with the rest of the
animal kingdom. But the Foundation were horrified
to find that the larval stage of SCP-939
looks pretty much identical to a human baby.
Researchers who were ordered to
dissect these creatures - finding out,
in the process, that they were
identical to human infants on the
inside, too - were offered amnestics due to the
understandably traumatic nature of the experience
One of the births was stillborn, and
the others quickly cannibalized it.
The surviving beasts soon learned to perfectly
imitate the voices and behavior of human children,
offering yet another reason that you cannot trust
any of your senses when it comes to SCP-939.
As they grew and matured, the more human parts
simply fell off, like a snake shedding its skin,
after a period of prolonged pain and
discomfort. More so than most creatures
the Foundation contains, SCP-939’s very existence
is enough to cause a sense of existential dread.
And for a creature as full of surprises
as SCP-939, of course there would be
another twist in the long, red tail. You see, we
mentioned earlier that the SCP Foundation briefly
considered using AMN-C227 - the amnestic gas
exhaled by 939 specimens - as a form of Class B
amnestics. However, this plan was later canceled,
when a horrifying side effect came to light.
Amnesia is never a good feeling. Having
complete blank spots in your memory is actually
extremely distressing to experience. And as we
mentioned earlier, people exposed to AMN-C227
seem to experience a palpable sense of deja vu.
When they first experience it, it’ll be mild,
but it’ll slowly get stronger as they
move towards the source. Little by little,
you’ll feel satisfaction drawing closer,
until you’re wandering into a deep, dark cave.
And before you know it, a set of red jaws are
closing around your neck, and it’s all over.
That’s right: AMN-C227 not only wipes
the memories of encounters with SCP-939,
it also lures any survivors back
into the lair of the creatures.
They’ve been given the Keter Class, because
there’s a whole species of these things,
and even the Foundation’s best scientists can’t
know for sure how far their habitats extend.
They could be waiting for you right now,
ready to call to you in a friendly voice.
So remember, kids, don’t believe everything
you hear. After all, sounds can be deceiving.
Now go check out “Evil Monster Created by SCP
Foundation SCP-2419 - The Laughing Men” and
“SCP-002 The Living Room & the Most Terrifying
SCP Rooms” for more terrifying SCP creatures!